Deci conceptul de fundamentalism este esențial legat de
conceptul de măsurare în mecanica cuantică
înainte ca mecanica cuantică să fie dezvoltată
era în general cunoscut
de oamenii de știință că dacă ai un sistem care se află
într-o anumită stare
și efectuezi o măsurătoare asupra lui, vei obține
un rezultat bine determinat
în mecanica cuantică asta nu mai e valabil, poți avea
un sistem care se află într-o stare perfect bine definită
și totuși când efectuezi anumite
măsurători asupra lui poți obține rezultate aleatoare
deci ca să ilustrez mai bine conceptul ăsta
trebuie să introduc conceptul de superpoziție
superpoziția este un concept care nu e chiar intuitiv
se bazează pe afișarea simultană
a mai multor combinații liniare de stări
în același timp și poți să te gândești la asta
de exemplu ca la un val radio care transportă
mai multe frecvențe diferite, nu e nimic
surprinzător în asta
ce dă aroma cuantică superpoziției este faptul
că măsori sistemul
deci o să ilustrez cu un exemplu
imaginează-ți că ai un sistem de săgeți
și pregătești sistemul
astfel încât toate săgețile să arate spre stânga
și apoi mergi și
pui sistemului întrebarea: ești sus sau jos?
și fiecare săgeată, pentru că săgețile arată spre stânga, poate fi
exprimată, descrisă
ca o combinație liniară de superpoziție între
sus și jos, vei obține
ca rezultate cincizeci la sută sus
și cincizeci la sută jos când pui întrebarea ești sus sau jos
obții acel rezultat de la sistem
și apoi poți pregăti cu asta
o stare diferită a sistemului în care jumătate
arată spre sus și jumătate arată
spre jos și pui aceeași întrebare
și obții același rezultat
sunt două sisteme foarte diferite
și ai obținut aceeași informație
de mai multe ori acum
cum poți determina care e diferența?
sistemele sunt foarte diferite
pentru că în primul caz ai pregătit sistemul într-o
stare pură, există o întrebare pe care
o poți pune sistemului care îți va da un rezultat determinist
nu aleator, și acea întrebare este: ești la stânga sau la dreapta?
îți va spune o sută la sută că e la stânga
în al doilea caz nu există nicio întrebare pe care
să o pui ca să îți dea o sută la sută același răspuns
pentru că e un amestec
deci dacă întrebi stânga sau dreapta
o să fie aleator pentru că jumătate sunt sus
jumătate jos, dacă întrebi sus sau jos
același lucru, o să fie cincizeci la sută
cum se leagă asta de aleatoriu?
poți să-ți imaginezi că e
similar cu aruncarea unei monede, o să fie cap sau pajură
dar nu e ca și cum arunci o monedă de fapt
pentru că atunci când arunci moneda
singurul motiv pentru care nu știi rezultatul pe care îl vei obține
este pentru că nu cunoști
energia cu care ai aruncat moneda, unghiul de moment,
condițiile ambientale din cameră
și așa mai departe, deci dacă ai ști toate astea
ai putea prezice cap sau pajură
sunt variabile ascunse observatorului
și timp de mulți ani oamenii de știință au crezut că există
variabile similare în mecanica cuantică care
se manifestă ca aleatoriu
și nu a fost până la
lucrarea de referință a lui John Bell din anii șaizeci că de fapt
s-a demonstrat că nu e cazul
și acum orice fizician
recunoaște că nu există nicio teorie cu variabile ascunse
care să fie compatibilă cu mecanica cuantică
deci este cu adevărat adevărat că atunci când măsori un sistem
natura îți dezvăluie un rezultat aleator
nu contează cât timp mă gândesc la asta, tot
mi se pare uimitor